hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play the groundskeeper
now I'm actually pretty excited about
this because all the music and sounds
engineering was done by the creators of
the game and not just like royalty free
stuff so I'm actually pretty pretty
interested in what this could be because
I say that sound is a big part of this
okay basic basic there is no sprinting
get the pause keys room tape recorders
black doors represent Middleham
got it this dude hey I never thought
this happened me what a boo me was that
a plane crashing that's not good
Here I am alone okay I have to find a
way out of here you're not alone you
have me and the entirety of the people
watching this although maybe at the end
of this game you're already dead but I
don't know okay oh hey whoa that is a
crashed plane how did he survive that
why is it sticking out of the ground
like that oh well whatever okay so I
seem to be in a bit of a forest
following a road of some sort oh nice
trees oh I love how they undulate like
that I love when things undulate for me
ladies though I all right I don't know
what I'm supposed to be expecting here
let me crank up my volume a bit seems to
be kind of bland no I'm not gonna save I
don't think that this is a page
collection mechanic style game I'm
pretty sure that this is just very very
original I'm gonna stay original I'm
gonna give this game the full benefit of
the doubt obviously it's made on the
Unity engine if you couldn't tell
there's a very distinct look to the
trees in the Unity engine at least the
default ones anyway I don't even know
what that sign said I didn't even read
it it just pointed an arrow okay I think
it said cat Oh it said cabin okay here
we go
this is a lovely establishment you have
your black door okay hello is anybody
home
anybody want any of me that is some
lovely music you got playing over there
all right okay whoo nice painting kind
of creepy but whatever how do I open
this oh there we go press the e button
the universal use button on anything
hello
aren't you lovely oh hello hey I got a
key what did that do
why did picking up the key make the door
unlock sound okay so oh hi I just got to
find what door this goes to right
all right then oh here we go that was
easy I hope the rest are just as easy
hello I'm gonna pop outta me someone
gonna jump scare me this seems like a
game that would have a few jump scares
with that oh it's an old-timey telephone
someday they're gonna invent a telephone
where you just press buttons you're
crazy
my name is Jeremy clich today is
November 17th okay I wasn't seven and
there's some strange things happening
around here my neighbor's ground keeper
has been wandering and yelling on my
property late at night bastard I don't
know why I'm livin recording this I
guess he's just really starting to get
to me okay I tried to talk with the stud
worths
but he always tells me they're out of
time I don't know what's going on here
but I don't like it
right okay so so what about that Oh what
about that Oh what about that
so the groundskeeper which is the name
of the game is some creepy douche
okay alright so that's how it's gonna be
it's gonna be one of these games huh
I don't think that's how you play chess
I'm pretty sure I had a feeling it was
good old my I had a feeling it was gonna
be a little scary okay all right
as imagining is like these are my last
words dick but ah how does it don't want
that oh no leave I don't think so
I'm not ready to leave I'm ready to be
jumped scared some more weight that go
to here no hang on whoa whoa whoa oh
wait I just made a loop-de-loop
it wasn't there what a hammer oh that's
an axe okay is it the act the
groundskeeper used to murder me and
might I say that the groundskeeper kind
of looks like an alien
you know suit white face aleni yeah what
is that
hi how you doing where'd you go where'd
you go
leave me alone stay away from me
somebody please save me there is no
you're give it a little mixed signals
here and I take that why can't I take
that if there was some demonic
monstrosity after me I think I'd take
the nearest weapon I could find locked I
got one more key but I don't know if it
just points out maybe does hello what's
in here that music is awfully nice
slightly creepy not too creepy here ah
now every time I open it really really
is that that phone downstairs dad that
phone down here that that phone
downstairs alright I'll play your game
you rogue bring it on I don't you know
who I am my name is markiplier and I'm
pretty good at yelling oh oh you're
watching me okay
leave now I must say this game has
really good audio engineering haha
alright wait am I actually supposed to
leave and why can i oh good that stuff
this game is really good sounded I love
good sound in a horror game I mean like
sound is like the big move that's new
what happened here huh a white-faced
alien man he I keep thinking these are
keys but they're just like books there's
something in thumb thumb company some
thumb oh oh bathroom I can't wait to
wash up okay yeah great idea thank you
why is there no mirror this is a
weirdest bathroom I've ever seen in my
life that will design could use some
tweaking but wait a minute I just went
in a big circle what was the point of
that I don't know oh the last key I got
must Bend the key to leave okay maybe I
was supposed to be not brave and try the
door to leave and it was like but me you
know me I'm just like braveness juice
shooting out of my eyeballs I can't stop
it it's like a gushing torrent of
Awesome oh come on what am I supposed to
do I wha I'm confused you want me to
leave or do you not want me to leave
what do you want me to do here a little
bit can be front door no there door I
haven't opened yet there anything I have
it open yet it's already been hmm
little restrain a little bit you don't
know what's going on had to be something
with his bathroom this bathrooms too
weird just to be nothing there's gotta
be something maybe I need to take a beer
dump the story don't crap my own pants
oh oh
okay he does look like an alien or a
plague doctor I knew there had to be
something there that was not easy to see
use the key to escape I could not wait a
minute are you Clint
or are you the groundskeeper mr.
Whiteface I'm a little confused but I
think I can get this oh okay
so somehow the key or never mind you
know what never mind I'm back outside
that's all that matters hi okay follow
the path that is the role of all the
paths right back to the front door okay
that all right then
I guess we'll take the other branching
paths and actually read the sign that I
didn't before whatever you say bro
whatever you say bring bring hello Oh
klitz cabin oh that makes so much sense
okay
I'm guessing this other path must go
whew so many choices do I want to go to
the well Manor or live well if I'm going
progressively upwards from Cabin the
lodge would make sense I I think anyway
maybe the well but I'm definitely not
good enough to go the manor yet that is
way above my pay grade
oh the undulating forest how I have
missed thee okay can I go in here no
this look a lot like the cabin from Anna
hey I remember that oh here we go
you know anything else I should know
about nope okay here we go inside I'm
ready this looks a lot like the cabin
except there's an ominous red glow
coming from over there
oh I think I should investigate oh good
that's a slightly less reassuring noise
you're making
okay what do I not need keys here see
keys stop it what happened is anything
what happened I didn't see Hey I feel so
alone I haven't seen the stutters in
days and my friend Jeremy clutch
disappeared last night I went over his
house and as I was approaching and I
mrs. Sutter scouts keeper screaming
through the trees as I entered his house
I was surprised at how much of a mess it
was I then heard someone bumping around
in the other room
and I'm as fast as I couldn't locked all
my doors call me paranoid but there's
definitely something wrong here
something wrong here
Oh how's that oh I see you but are you
real are you real
maybe the wall are you real stay out a
stud worth haha I am scudworth cuz I'm
stuck Dudley Matt Manliness okay I hear
that okay
got a weird-ass lodges this nobody got
hiding away in here
Howard's go he's been standing in my
front yard past hour
hey watching okay wait he's out there
anymore okay hi what are you doing
remind me that guy that was yelling at
his cat doesn't remember us I knew was
gonna happen again I knew you were gonna
do it you dick dick bag bag oh oh wait
oh okay I guess I'm out of here I'm out
of here baby
who needs that why did I even go in
there
did that have a point did I need to go
in there I don't think I did all right
continuing on moving forward and by
moving forward I mean moving backwards
until we get to the manor of the well
I'm gonna save the manor for last and go
well next I guess I really don't know
how long this game is I thought it would
have just been a shorty wordy but no
it's got some substance to it I like it
with a well I guess we please you've
gotta help us he's got us trapped down
here but who our ground chicken he's
going crazy
he locks on the bottom of the well but
who are you what's going on I'm Charles
stone he's crazy it's crazy who keeps
you - I'm Rosie will who just gotta get
us out of here you gotta get out of here
white no time there's no time there's no
time you have to calm down tell me
what's going on
tell oh please you lock us down here
created through the basement it's done
with man listen listen to me please
there's a spare key it's behind the
mansion you've gotta get it you gotta
save us please
what how do you know he's not still
there I know he's here I know he's still
living here because I can hear her
frantically pacing each and every night
down here in the basement there's no
time there's no time there's no time
there's no time and didn't I hear
there's no time before something about
no time and staying away from stud worth
Manor those seem to be warnings for me
what is this place anyway what kind of
town or city or village or little
settlement is this got a groundskeeper
for a bajillion trees it's got a cabin a
Lodge in a manner weird does you make
any sense
hop it I'll put the trees stop
undulating so close to me I see you
coming in on the road there normally I
like the undulation but not not today
there oh gosh where's this manner
where's this matter bring it on bring it
on bring it on maybe I don't know well
my going it's just endless
but on some benny hill me as haha I'm
startled by the noise we're just walking
watching that guy Oman to get you this
creepy little I'm gonna get you walk
that's all that that was hilaryford okay
yeah I I did it placed gate key below
okay so he said there's a key behind the
manor ergo I should go back there
maybe hobbit where's this ah got it
I mean let me loop the other way around
I hang on actually gotta close
okay why is that a thing
okay and it I had Skype on online
instead of Do Not Disturb though whoops
my bad
you guys aren't any Skype noises I
apology
um listen it'll funk on that [ __ ] hey
what's up here I know that open but
what's oh I can't go up there Norman
alright the manner I'm sure that all all
of my questions will be answered oh this
is just a live poll hey alright then
good good so jump-scares that time lots
of whispering hi buddy hey get out of
here with your creepy yeah
did I pick up some I thought I smited
Phoenix what's going on okay
all right then no clock okay
I think I picked up a key I'm not sure
but I think I did
so there's got to be another door here
that's not all boarded up Nonna's yes
that's boarded up as well that's boarded
up over there so oh did I get shut up
don't you even try to dick with me I
Mundek Abul yeah that's what I said
I'm staying with it I don't oh well
thank you why the hell how am I supposed
to know what door to go through uh-huh
found you
all right okay you really want to get in
bed with me I understand I'm quite
handsome I know we just hired the
greatest groundskeeper to tender manner
great work he's been getting really
close with our family I mean I consider
him to be the brother I never had
you rooms as long as he's with us I
think nothing will ever go wrong
although it is strange how much he's
obsessed with clocks he has multiple
watches on his wrist he says he likes to
keep exact track of how much time he's
losing yeah he changed who changed I
wonder who you're talking about okay so
I got a tape recorder that kind of
unlocked doors before I don't know if I
need to go down or up oh well I'm luck
[ __ ] bag [ __ ] Gus hi hey there hello
oh you know all right hello baby I are
you a baby
my groundskeepers been acting really
strange recently
yeah bro seems like his obsession with
time has become more of an addiction
yeah he seems like he's becoming private
and jittery oh yeah seems as if his
body's becoming inhabited by nothing
yeah cuz that's something that a teenage
radical kid would say his body's
inhabited with like nothing man
totally dude bro I'm so old our night
this is what teenagers say right you
know radical all right totally cool bro
totes mix Krauts none
squee
who's in here huh oh I got a kid I think
good hey was the point of that was the
point at who's the boy there's no other
doors that I can unlock that one's
boarded up boarded up boarded up not
boarded up there's no other doors
boarded up boarded up open open that one
was boarded up too what am I supposed to
do oh wait a minute oh yeah that was
actually hard to find
okay let's boldly go into the basement
where no man has gone before except
those that were dragged there kicking
and screaming hey stay out he lives down
here oh he lives down there wait a
minute
I have an idea what's going on
he's trying to trick me they managed to
trap him down here well I'm about to
unleash him apparently or something oh
good stairs
all right okay
all right I like this and by like I mean
hey a lot Oh yep
you go you go [ __ ] let's go oh we got
quite a oh no no oh I take why are you
doing this
my time is coming apparently okay
good to know thanks Bree
thanks food thanks for you so now oh I
just need to do what exactly
cuz I don't really know look another bed
or you're gonna aggressively shove the
bed towards me no apparently not um I
don't see anything
wait what was that what did I do
something happened something happened I
heard it oh I see there's a 100k no I
did I press that button did that open
the gate or something maybe Hey
oh did I see you do you know well let's
see my lights dead it had to be now yeah
I might have had to be now Oh
oh goody gumdrops I like this I like
this a lot I like it I like it so much
this is the greatest hour like being in
here oh oh yes
oh what's that I see a constant light
okay going towards it who's it I saw
something
I saw something why is there a constant
light in here ah there's something
important he's walking around his knee
that's him no no no no no no no no no no
oh okay all right I did it
but you need to get out to find who hid
out need to find a way out
you'd find out Bray is Babu beautiful
babe Nina fun with her
hello is that you is that it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter hurry just get
the key the keys underneath the table in
the room behind you okay I'm hurrying Oh
I killed him everybody I got him
don't you worry don't look right behind
you don't look in your closet don't
think about him appearing in your
doorway as you're sleeping don't think
about him waking up and then I'm seeing
distance clothes from your face don't
blink or anything hi he's dead don't
worry you won't come get you now it's
really good by the way I gotta say super
duper awesome I mean obviously level
design and the art was not anywhere
nearly as good as the sound but the
sound was so good I mean the gameplay
elements I was kind of like yeah it's
not good find a key to open the door to
find another door to open the key tape
recorder opens ignore I didn't like that
too much I think they could have done
that better but the sound was so good
all that sound was so good amazing
amazing job on the sound design if they
teamed up if the guys who made this game
teamed up with like someone who's really
good at like level design and character
modeling and animation stuff like that
you could make an amazing game but
either way it was really good so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
dance taste for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Oh